so the question is why did you could get
up
and you mean and
so far we're at
as i come around
i don't i don't want him to do
a double leg or a single leg takedown go
ahead
the answer is not that anybody that goes
down
tries to get up says that would not be
good
that's not good jiu jitsu i have
pressure here
he should yield with that pressure and
go into newaza
okay
so so far in our reasoning we're like
well if i'm in a place where he does not
take me down
then he has to go to plan b and can plan
b
b he sees height
okay so if i
stay in front of him at any point
the double leg single leg is going to be
viable
so i have to stay in the back
so i'm in the back but if i stay here
he can go tight on the circle and get me
again
so staying in the back must be dynamic
where i keep going and i keep moving
around
but if i'm the one moving around
go he's going to get a tighter circle
than me
so i'll i'll inverse it
he keeps moving around forward
[Music]
i just gotta watch this
that's my experiment right now prolonged
[Music]
so every time
you're gonna see that he tries to get
this arm
i'm going to drop this
there right as he picks it up to go
here i keep it moving go
and he has to choose between balance
brace leg attack now prolonged
[Music]
okay let's try it so you know
in the last row
i'm just trying to keep this going i
want to extend it to get a sense of it
but at which point does
the middleware start to uh
not work for him so we're gonna go slow
okay
what do you think
[Music]
what's exposed his back
do you see so
you're you're gonna have the back and he
doesn't want
that
let's look at the geometry too so
because i'm in this corner
let's say he's uh he he's ideally he's
let's just say not ideally but once i
got his back here
right this is where i'm going to go on
meaning in the last drill as i come
around
this is just extend extend extend
extending
but i only extend it
to his there
that's it okay attack
back mouth rear naked that's what you're
doing
okay
so your uke should feel that whoa
what's he want to do he wants to stand
up
he wants to get the hell out of there
get the hell out of there
boom get the hell out of there
and fight me
there
[Music]
and he's trying to get his back from
being mounted boom
so as he starts to stand boom
this is where i see
[Music]
that
so you're drilling here
attack back mount rear naked
boom pop right there
attack back map we're making then we'll
add the second one go
[Music]
expose the back
figure it out when you get down
okay he's gonna look for the back face
to open to him just like
any time you take back mount rear naked
it's exactly the same so he's going to
go
he's going to push her forward there it
is a little more
there it is then he goes
again smoother stay inside
go go back face there it is
again notice when
he gets that back face
right there okay let's try it again
so
okay so as i'm doing the technique
i have to i have to
make the single leg double leg
tactically inferior how do i do that
by exposing the back when i expose the
back
of course the idiot would continue but
that's going to give you the rear naked
but the good fighter is going to get the
f out of there
and get their back
from not being exposed how
they will bring their head up which is
why when you're trying to take the back
from guard or
side scissor you're more successful
in your attack if your head remains
higher than
their head if they get their head
higher than you
okay i'm over here and i'm going to
come around and try to get his back
if his head is higher than mine you're
not getting the back
okay
so he is trying to get his head
up and his hips away from me
so i lose the back mount
but that means i have to expose that
then he realizes get his head up and get
his hips
out so i don't get hooks and all that
and it's that energy that i use
that we always do
so i make his back bone a little cool
and then he
when i talked about the kazushi
it's as he's as he's trying to get his
hips underneath him and his head up
go back he's trying to unexpose his back
this
he's going to get his hips under and his
he gets rid of the backwards push or i
go into the tilt
back exposure he counters i go into the
tilt
now keep your feet where they are
put your hand down and make your hand
like you're pushing but don't move your
feet
i don't feel any of this force because
i'm at the edge of his action
go back if i'm here
and he pushes push then i'll feel his
force
but if i'm at the edge of his body
i'm just doing jiu jitsu i'm at zero
pressure
okay i'm not capping and i'm not trying
to stop him
so when i do the tilt although he's
oriented towards me
there's no mass on me he's not
on me because i'm not here i'm over here
with zero pressure
do you see
which is why the entry is so
easy the entry is easy
if he was leaning on me
i would not be able to enter
so you have to be at zero pressure when
you do the tilt
pull
back exposure tilt
it was a class on the question why did
zuki get up
but since we're doing it eating me knock
it
okay there's the back exposure as he
gets
up you can't have that arm inside you
again this is not an evening
so you have to obey all the rules
stay in the box boom block your
boom keep that same arm trap
[Music]
this is how you give me nugget here i'm
going to do a stance
change i have an intern i have not
occupied new space there's nothing
on it you're doing that because you
don't have the yin entry and he's heavy
though you're like here and you go here
and then
again the injury is effortless
entry is effortless he's not in the way
okay so i don't need to change stances
to do it i should be able to do a
yumiyashi
okay